let's be real when it comes to summer
celeb vacations don't suck on a popular
hot spot for these stars is Mexico
Mexico is so popular right now because
you know what it's closed and it's got
really good food who doesn't love a taco
Kevin Hart apparently does just check
out these beautiful shots from his
Mexican getaway with wife and Nico
parish and speaking of shots George
Clooney and Randy Gerber love their
tequila well who can drink who under the
table we're never under the table we're
usually up above or on the table and
it's their adventures and Mexico that
inspired cos amigos
they came a point where George said to
me why don't we just make our own like
one that's perfect for us
how's this for perfect Kourtney
Kardashian ring in her 38th birthday in
Mexico with all her girls aka the
Calabasas mom Cruz other stars known to
vacay south of the border Jennifer
Aniston and Justin Theroux Kristin
Cavallari and Jade Cutler and Julianne
Hough who is still recovering from her
epic bachelorette party in Cabo I had a
couple of phone calls and I was like I
don't know can't do everything yes yeah
everything